what's the biggest lesson you've learned  in the last decade for you  that things first of all keep getting  better  i think in our society especially as for  at least to you know as you get older at  least in my family there was a lot of  kind of cultural expectations like oh  over this age it kind of starts going  down or you know what i mean you're kind  of you peak when you're young and that's  when all the good stuff happens and for  me  i feel like it keeps getting better  and i love  that  the best years are still ahead of me and  that all the stuff that i've been  through there's like all of these  exciting new possibilities so that's one  of the biggest lessons